-The Oscars were last night.
Here to talk about it is
one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, with her very own
Oscars recap!
[ Applause ]
-Yay!
Hey, everybody. Hey, Seth.
You guys, there is nothing like
the magic of the Oscars,
and last night was no exception.
First things first --
Beyoncé's performance
was breathtaking.
Her song about how good it is
to be alive
made me feel
so good to be alive.
It just filled me with hope, a
hope that would never dissipate.
Then, Troy Kotsur won
for "CODA" and Seth,
when the audience stood up
and applauded in sign for him,
it was quite the moment --
a moment that would surely
be the focus of the evening.
[ Laughter ]
Then, during a performance of
"We Don't Talk About Bruno,"
Megan Thee Stallion rapped,
and it was heaven.
It's things like these
that make you feel like
you're having a moment
with all of America.
And then, here's a sentence
we will say
for the rest of our lives --
Will Smith slapped Chris Rock.
[ Laughter ]
And life as we know it
changed forever.
[ Laughter ]
I had hoped that it was a bit,
but that hope quickly
turned to dust.
A dark sadness filled my home,
a darkness I couldn't escape.
Had the Oscars lost its magic?
My sister, Lacey, called me,
and we screamed.
We screamed a long, loud scream
of excitement?
Terror? I don't know.
But we screamed it
with all of America.
We tried to stay engaged,
but there was no more show
after that.
There was no more anything!
The once-fluffy couch
I was sitting on
suddenly felt like
hard and unwelcoming.
My heated blanket went cool.
The sweet tea I was enjoying
lost all its flavor.
The Oscars took everything
I thought I knew
and flushed it down the toilet.
In this new world,
could I survive?
I know now why they don't have a
category for Best Horror Movie,
because the best horror movie
is the Oscars.
Lacey called back,
this time with FaceTime.
I needed to see
her screaming face
to know I wasn't dreaming.
And then it happened.
The announcer said, "And the
Oscar for Best Actor goes to..."
and all of America collectively
held their breath,
bit their cuticles,
and then Will Smith won
for Best Actor!
His acceptance speech lasted for
5 minutes and 25 seconds,
and I did not breathe for
5 minutes and 25 seconds!
The Earth cracked open
and I slipped through.
I heard echoes of "I'm sorry,
but never to Chris Rock"?
I -- I'm not sure what he said,
because again,
I'm in the center of the Earth
at this point.
It comes to an end,
and I scroll Twitter
and I read jokes and thinkpieces
and opinions about it,
and while I felt like I had seen
something horrible and private
that made me feel great shame,
I found out everyone in America
felt the same way I did.
[ Laughter ]
And that, my friends,
is the magic of the Oscars!
[ Sparkling sound ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]